Wesley first of all congratulations a
big victory with the black pieces
against uh the defending Champion the
2022 Manchester Champion alireza firoza
always such a dangerous opponent I
almost forgot yeah he's very dangerous I
mean very happy to get a Revenge from
that important game the thing felt cup
and again I'll glory to Jesus for the
win but uh he was he's he was playing
very ambitiously uh
okay there were several interesting
moments of the game also the opening was
quite interesting in the middle game but
yeah you tried this idea with Bishop to
B6 and then you can be five yeah I think
he got too ambitious because
for last year he was playing for a win
every single game with both colors if
you remember his game against Maxim yeah
from last year yeah so but he's a very
good very very young player so tell us a
bit about this idea with Bishop 6a5 we
generally see Bishop B6 with 97 ideas
Fabiano who first played this
who made this bishop B6 more popular I
think he's started playing in Paris two
years ago
and well
after play detail I realized he was
gonna play in Bishop G5 no matter what
and I didn't really prepare that much so
that's why I went for this move order I
think Richard report played a similar
line before leaving the Knight on G8 for
for the moment yeah so that he cannot
play the pin because every time plays
Bishop G5 you can meet it with F6
or Knight G7 very interesting but uh
yeah I mean there were several
interesting moments I thought Knight G7
was also possible but maybe
the best
but uh
anyway I think the choco piano you can
play it in so many ways right it becomes
confusing uh at times yeah you gotta
vanished gear for advice because if you
made the adjustable course on the
Italian with A4 stuff but uh I thought
that was slightly worse out of the
opening but nothing special I like the
movie shop E6 uh I mean he was still
playing quickly but uh
yeah Megan plays love with Rook C1 but
he decided to force matters yes
yes I thought wipes a bit better here
but then I equalized very quickly on
after an ibd2 like I wasn't sure how to
play I
think Queen F4 me maybe a slight mistake
so you were assessing this position as
more or less balanced equal very close
to equality very close to equality but I
don't think I was playing well because I
was moving my queen back and forth
so it wasn't at this point he had a
golden opportunity I think it was this
moment Queen to F6 it felt like you are
more or less maintaining the balance in
the position and this move Queen to G6
he had this idea of Queen to D1 did you
spot it yeah yeah Queen G6 I probably
played it too quickly I was about three
minutes you spent three minutes on this
one yeah because I know if he was trying
to hit me on the clock so I started
moving faster
uh but I guess after Queen D1
what did I miss here oh Queen D1
uh well the idea is that he cannot I
mean he can take on A4 but you have
Queen to be one ideas right yeah and I
think Rook 28 was a move that the engine
was recommending Queen V1 yeah I I
even off the road today it's not looking
great somehow I missed
yeah me I saw Queen the one but I
totally underestimated it uh oh because
the idea is that
I guess the king
on G2
yeah did you just play slow like this
and then at the right moment you stick
on A4 no I was weird but windy one I
just decided to make a move
um but uh because I thought I was
equalizing here maybe Queen E6 is more
accurate and then take and then try to
force matters yeah yeah I mean gets to
play Queen C1
it felt like you were happy with the
repetition obviously with the black
pieces not a bad result yes if my pawns
on A6 or A5 maybe black can play for
Advantage
so very hard to protect when did you
feel like you're finally starting to
have something you play this ambitious
move G5 but yeah I think he was he just
missed G5 because the idea is that
compared to the other position
uh
if I go Queen Rook takes the idea of The
Rook on E7 he's got Queen A8 or
something
repeater
oh but maybe it doesn't work okay never
mind
I think we yeah okay I think this is
still some still okay
I will throw him with G5 but this was a
very good practical try yeah right now
you're starting to put the pressure on
him yeah at least from a practical
perspective right yeah a little time
and it looks very good maybe hg5 in here
oh you can still make up there with 95
95 sacrifice Upon take Stakes take
Stakes he's going to take with the queen
then Queen to B4
just Target both Pawns
but yeah I wasn't happy when I played G5
if he takes like this maybe just take on
C7 okay C7 oh no never mind okay but
this is such a difficult move to see
yeah rookie Rook F1 yeah this is not
easy oh yeah
and like it's still better to say the
least yes so he played Knight H4 which
gave you questions with another blender
Genji one yeah because the point is that
if I take with the queen then the pawn
age desperate after is protected
yeah so I don't have to use protected
very nice they say blenders mistakes
come in robes
especially in time travel yeah right
well okay he reached move 40 so you
should have found King G1
but uh he was playing quickly
did that surprise you at all did you
feel because he hasn't played since the
singfield cup uh In classical
tournaments did you feel like he's a
little bit Rusty
maybe maybe I mean I wasn't taking any
chances I was just playing it like a
normal game you cannot underestimate
fruit especially after he reached he had
that monster term in a few months ago
where he reached 2800
so maybe he's a little bit uh Rusty
um I mean another few place
on title juicy here and there feels for
me the only place he plays
but uh
but he'll get there you know I mean
chess requires really a lot of focus
he's a brilliant player he's a very
talented but uh
if you
want to be the best in the world
together really focus on the game
there's something about Bucharest for
you you always seem to be very
comfortable here you score quite well as
well what is it about it
uh well I I know the people
I
have friends here I live my fourth time
the organization is great you played
every single year yeah yeah
I won't miss it for anything and no it's
good to know I like it I like our
football tournaments because it's nice
to meet familiar faces you know
Wesley will let you get some rest it was
a long game and we'll see you tomorrow
yeah thank
you thank you guys back are you
Christian congratulations West